we knew from the onset that a big hero 6
was going to be
uniquely challenging
uh we knew from the from the very
beginning that it was going to be an
emotionally ambitious story
uh we knew that there were going to be a
lot of disparate elements that we're
going to have to try to pull together
into a cohesive whole
and at times we felt like there was two
two distinct
genres we were trying to meld together
into one thing and there were a lot of
characters so we knew this was going to
be a really challenging film
so we relied on
methods that we use at disney that
really emphasize collaboration and
iteration
as far as collaboration goes one of the
primary responsibilities of the director
is to
come up with a strong story
but you're going to be surrounded by
really talented really amazing people
who are going to help you and so one of
the most important things you can do
is reach out and pull the best ideas out
of the people that are assembled and so
collaborative environments really
important
but that kind of environment can be
difficult to achieve in reality
um because
in in some ways it fights human nature
we all want to be told all the time that
all our ideas are amazing and every
thought we have is gold and wow mr
williams mr hall you've done it again uh
how do you do it how do you do it
but if that's all you ever get the story
is not going to get any better so you
have to really fight the the very human
desire for affirmation
and you have to actively foster an
environment where people feel
comfortable disagreeing with you if
that's how they feel and disagreeing
with each other that's how they feel we
really want that honest and open debate
because one thing you can't
overemphasize is the fact that when it
comes to story conflict is good
and and disagreement is good because in
that collision
between two contradictory ideas uh
oftentimes a third and better idea will
emerge that we've never seen the light
of day had there not been that vigorous
discussion so that's what we want in our
story rooms
um the flip side of that is that even as
you're disagreeing you have to be
respectful of other people's points of
view
because when you talk story
you make yourself very vulnerable
when you talk about story you're talking
about you'll end up in the story room
for hours and days on end talking about
things that you love
things that you hate
things that make you sad
and you're really pulling from your own
life experience
so when you offer an idea
to some extent you're saying this is who
i am
and that line between who you are and
what you do starts to become very fuzzy
so it's really important to find that
place where you can be honest and open
but never let things get personal
um i think we have yes we have slides
here of uh don and i
in the store go back to that other slide
real quick garth
look how exciting that is
look at that energy look at it
it's just it's amazing it's just it
really captured the raw energy look
there's that of the biggest discussion i
was touting look at it look at it
i'm very interested you should mention
because most people here i would wager
most people have never been in a disney
story room and you should very briefly
describe
why is it set up that way what is all
that stuff what's the purpose of the
pictures on top the pictures on the
bottom
oh well we usually we we've had this
convenient little space at the top of
our story rooms uh that i think back on
bolt we began the tradition of pinning
up big pieces of his dev art that would
stay up there to be a a visual
inspiration
um and the story room itself becomes a
real uh sanctuary it's a home away from
home
and and we will spend hours and days and
weeks and years on end
in this room it really is the creative
center for the story department and it
really hub and it's a hub for the whole
production
and it's where we'll work out the
outline there's the outline on the on
the back wall there all the cards uh
you'll you'll work with the story team
on the outline the outline will continue
to evolve over the course of the years
of production
you'll meet with writers and talk about
the scenes they'll often write a scene
and come back
we'll have a story artist take the scene
go off and board it and bring it back
pitch it in this room to the story team
and begin the cycle over and over and
over again of rewriting re-boarding uh
and and and restructuring the film it
all happens in this room uh and and i
should talk i should i think it's worth
mentioning
that the people who work in these kind
of environments the writers and the
story artists they have to have a very
thick skin
because often your job is to go off on
your own and work on a scene and and
create something that hopefully you like
and you think serves the film and
something you become very invested in
and after
one or two weeks of work you'll come
back into the story room and you have to
pitch it and you have to pitch it with
passion and conviction and you have to
believe in it and then you have to turn
a switch and you have to sit down and
listen to people whose job it is to
judge that idea and they'll tell you
what they like what they didn't like
what they do differently
and you have to be receptive to these
other points of view even if at first
you don't agree
um because it in that in that conflict
you may find that third and better idea
um and all of this iteration all of this
rewriting rebording it's all sort of
working towards a screening there's
always a screening looming
and our screenings are are a real
milestone for the production we'll do
between six and maybe eight or nine at
the most screenings
and who's in these screenings who is
sitting in these it's it's the crew
we'll cut it's all internal the crew
will come and watch it we'll often times
invite people in from other shows just
to get a fresh perspective
and and that's what it really is really
it's an opportunity to take stock of
where you're at on the film
you know bob eye girls show up allen
horn we'll have the big boys there we'll
also have uh you know the the marketing
teams come in just so that they can
start getting um you know it really is a
chance for us to all invest in what this
film is going to be